hey you guys flickers of fair time once
again
now this is a movie
that
i swear to god i saw this movie probably
like a million times when i was in high
school uh it was on cable all the time
it was like a really popular vhs rental
so this is one of those movies that just
kind of like in the late 80s and early
90s
was sort of like
integrated into my personality
but interestingly i hadn't seen it in a
really really long time i could i
remembered like so much about it i
remember lines from it i remembered
scenes from it but i hadn't seen it in
such a long time that i really wanted uh
you know particularly to do this one for
this show because i really wanted to
watch it again and see if it held up so
this is the movie the lady in white from
1988.
now i feel like this movie is maybe
i don't know i feel like maybe a lot of
people um that were kids or teenagers in
the late 80s
probably saw this um it it had a
theatrical release but it was really
kind of a bomb i think the movie
cost like five million dollars to make
so it's fairly low budget even for the
time but it only made like a million and
a half back
uh but subsequently like after it came
out on cable like it repeated on cable
all the time and like i said when it
came out on vhs i feel like it started
to develop a little bit of a cult
following but i don't know how how
well-known it is nowadays i did actually
find several other reviews of it uh on
youtube a lot of other horror channels
had reviewed it and interestingly um a
lot of the reviewers even if they were i
mean obviously the ones that were my age
like had a lot of nostalgic affection
for it but interestingly even the you
know the reviewers that were much
younger that hadn't seen this at the
time that it came out still really
really seemed to enjoy it and were like
you know this is like an unseen gem and
why doesn't anybody ever talk about this
movie which actually i would totally uh
agree with now this movie
it was written
directed produced and scored by frank
laluja now i don't know if he even ever
did any other movies like other than
this or like where his um where his
career went after that but it's like
really interesting because this is just
such a great i don't know this is just
such a great
ghost story slash murder mystery another
thing that's great about this movie well
there's there's many things but uh one
other thing that's great about this
movie is one since the beginning part of
it at least is set on halloween and like
uh particularly like early 1960s small
town new england halloween so it really
really this is a great movie to watch
around the halloween season because it
really kind of like puts you in the mood
it's like that old-fashioned small town
new england you know all the colored
leaves falling and like all the
jack-o'-lanterns on the little porches
and [ __ ] like that if you really want to
kind of get into that mindset then this
is a great one to watch like it kind of
it starts out on halloween and like goes
like a few months you know over the
course of the movie but
it definitely has that old school
halloween vibe to it so if you really
are looking for something
in that line to watch around halloween
time and you haven't seen this one then
this is definitely one you need to check
out another thing too is this is a great
movie
where
if you have kids
that you are looking to get into horror
because i know that there's like old
gothy and spooky people like myself that
even though i do not have children i do
know some other people
my age and a little bit younger who do
have kids and are really into horror and
are interested in getting their kids
into horror as well like you know to
kind of foster that interest um and
obviously you don't want to start them
off with like [ __ ] hostile or
anything like that when they're that age
but
this is a really good
family i guess horror movie um in this
and i'd still call it a horror movie
even though like i said somebody said
ghost story um you know murder mystery
now i will say that i don't think it's
it's probably not appropriate for like
real real young kids because there is
some swearing in it there's child murder
there's
racism uh there's all that kind of stuff
so it kind of deals with some heady
issues and it's kind of like a serious
tone
but just the way that it's shot
i think if your kid is like the same age
as the main protagonist of this maybe
like 9 or ten years old then it should
be totally fine so i kind of feel like
this movie you know something like this
is a little more grown up than say like
hocus pocus or something like that or
the witches although the witches is like
pretty traumatizing i actually kind of
want to do um do a review on that too
one day because i really like that but
this is kind of in that same ballpark
where if you're really looking to get
your 9 10 year old kids like your you
know pre-teen
kind of kids into horror this is
actually a good one to start with i will
say because it said in 1962 it doesn't
seem like an 80s movie although i will
say that some of the ghost effects look
a little bit
dated because they were green screened
and you know this was kind of a lower
budget movie so the green screen effects
don't look that fantastic but
i mean the story is really solid it's
just it's a creepy it just has a great
creepy atmosphere to it and it's just
like it's it's just a great great like
family halloween uh ghost story type of
movie to watch so if you haven't seen it
and that sounds like really cool you
want something to watch with your kids
you know this halloween that you haven't
seen then definitely this is one to
watch
so
what we have the story there's a little
boy named frankie scarlotti and he's
played by a very very young uh lucas
haas who as far as i know is still
acting uh he's been in a [ __ ] ton of
stuff since then and i think he's also a
musician
um but there and there's also like a ton
of other actors who will recognize in
this alex rocco is in it plays his dad i
think he was in some of the godfather
movies among many other things
catherine hellmund is in this who
if you were around in the 70s she was on
the sitcom soap and if you're around in
the 80s she was on the sitcom who's the
boss so she's been a lot of stuff too
she's also in this so this has like
pretty much every actor in this should
be like hey it's that guy or hey it's
that lady or helps you know everyone is
like super familiar so what ends up
happening is that frankie who was nine
years old uh back in 1962 like there's a
little bit of a thing at the beginning
where you're you're presumed you're
presuming that it's like a grown-up
frankie uh and he's a horror writer now
and he is going back to his hometown and
he's telling the cabbie cabby's asking
him do you really believe all that scary
stuff you read and he's standing by
these gravestones so then you kind of go
back and he's narrating a little bit
like talking about something that
happened when he was nine years old and
what perhaps started him off on you know
wanting to write horror ghost stories or
whatever
so it's halloween
frankie is uh going to school with his
little dracula mask on
his little cape and whatnot his little
pumpkin
and uh so he's going to class and
they're having a little halloween party
everyone it's like i said it's a very
halloweeny like old school halloween uh
the actual um town i think they shot it
in uh
lions new york like upstate new york but
the town is a fictional it's called
willow point falls i believe um but so
but the story like the the
kind of urban legend that they go into
in this movie a little bit of the lady
in white is based around a real lady in
white urban legend from rochester new
york which is where uh frank llozia the
guy that wrote and directed the movie
came from so he knew of that legend that
he wanted integrated in the movie so so
basically what happens like i said it's
halloween uh the kids are all very
excited frankie after school uh he kind
of
already he's kind of like telling
monster stories to the class and
everything but um on his way home
he kind of gets together with two of his
friends
frenemies i want to say it's really
considering the [ __ ] they do to him it
seems like frenemies more than anything
else even though he kind of hangs out
because this is just kind of it's such a
boy thing it's like they still hang out
together and like talk to each other
even though they're just like doing dick
moves to each other all the time but
yeah so he's got these two uh frenemies
donald and louie and they decide it
would be funny
to
basically they they plan this thing
where they steal his cap or like he has
like a little beanie like that his dad
gave him or something or his little hat
or whatever and they hide it in the
school's cloak room
and then so when he comes to find them
and he can't find it he's like oh maybe
he left it back in the cloakroom so when
he goes back to get it his friends like
dicks lock him in there now since nobody
knows where he is so not only this poor
kid locked in a [ __ ] cloak room but
he also he misses halloween night which
that really sucks right so he's locked
in this cloak room and he's like you
know freaking out and terrified and
everybody's gone from the school
and it's really super creepy
now while he's in there um he falls
asleep and he starts having like this
dream about his book presumably his mom
has died at some point uh you know in
the past and he's having like a dream
about her funeral
and then he wakes up
and he sees
a little like what is clearly an
apparition of a little girl in the
cloakroom and as he watches in horrified
fascination i guess we can call it
uh it appears that this little ghost
girl is being attacked and murdered by
an invisible assailant like it seems
like somebody comes in but you can't see
them and she starts talking to them and
then she starts getting like strangled
and stuff she falls on the floor so he's
freaking out about this uh as you would
because it's a very very clear ghost
[ __ ] happening and you know this little
ghost girl is you know laying there dead
now and then like she's kind of picked
up and taken out of the room by this
invisible person
and then at some point like somebody
comes into the cloakroom since he's
still kind of like freaked out by what
he just saw as you would be he attempts
to kind of like hide from that person
now it seems like this person is trying
to like find something that's like down
in the heating grate like in the floor
of the cloakroom and uh doesn't find it
but then finally he sees frankie he's
like sitting up on the shelf like up on
the cloakroom so he's kind of like
partially hidden
and at this point we don't see who this
person is um so because he doesn't know
who frankie is because frankie has his
little dracula mask on uh he basically
starts strangling the kid at which point
frankie has a kind of weird like
near-death experience
where he sees the little girl that he
saw in the vision
and she's basically like you know i
can't find my mom she's looking for her
mother
so frankie says in his you know
near-death experience thing that he's
going to help her
but then it turns out that frankie's dad
has shown up at the cloak room and they
figured out where he was because you
know after they found out that his
friend what his friends had done and
blah blah blah so they found out where
he was they came there uh his dad gave
him mouth to mouth and he uh was revived
now interestingly and this is where the
kind of the the the racial
aspect comes into it which actually i
had forgotten about
but because there's um a janitor
custodian that works at this school
and he had
gotten drunk and kind of like fallen
asleep in his office and since he was
the only other person on the school
grounds at the time he gets arrested for
attacking frankie now he and he's a
black man so that whole thing is going
on too
now it comes to light after this after
frankie is attacked
that you know it's kind of uh comes out
in the paper this is a small town and
everything
so it turns out that uh his that
frankie's brother gino
shows him this big newspaper article
which says that actually
10 other is it 10 or 11 i think it's 11
other kids have been murdered in willow
point falls
over the past decade
so as he's looking at this article the
first victim
looks just like the little girl like the
ghost girl that he saw in the cloakroom
and her name is
melissa
and as the point as the story goes on um
he sees melissa like more and more and
they almost kind of like establish this
little kind of relationship where like i
said he's promised to
help her find her mother uh you know
help find out what happened to her and
everything like that so to that end uh
he decides that he's going to go back to
the cloak room and look in that uh
heating grate because he uh figures out
because he's a pretty smart kid
he figures out that the killer must have
gone back
to find uh like a high school class ring
of his that he dropped down the grate
when he was murdering melissa
and he was going back to get it because
the school was going to be replacing uh
the heating system soon and he was
afraid that it would be discovered and
that it would be linked to him
so frankie goes back and he opens up the
great and he finds a bunch of stuff in
there like stuff from the other victims
like a barrette and stuff and he also
finds the class ring which has initials
on it so i mean before he even like gets
a chance to like tell his dad or the
police or anything about that his
jackass brother
like steals the ring for whatever reason
just because he's a jerk uh you know
because he doesn't really know what it
is now meanwhile while all this is going
on because there's that going on
uh but there's also
this whole legend about the lady in
white uh there's there's supposedly
there's this shack this little cottage
that's out by the cliffs uh you know on
the ocean
and uh there's supposedly this really
creepy woman in white that like lurks
around there that's looking for her
daughter or whatever
now
one night uh frankie and his little uh
frenemies
the ones who locked him in the closet
and almost got him killed so thanks kids
um you know what i mean why is he still
hanging out with these dishes i don't
know but it's like so so he is so they
go there
uh you know just like little boys do
it's just like it'll be super creepy
we'll go out and like look at the you
know cottage or whatever and they kind
of break in there and they actually see
the woman in white he's played by
katherine hellman and they freak out and
they run away while he's running away he
runs into his brother geno who is
looking for him and they figure out that
ghost girl melissa that he saw in the
cloak room she is essentially reenacting
her death like every night at the same
time
so
because he saw the first part of it when
he was locked in the cloak room and then
at one point she gets like it looks like
she's picked up by an invisible person
and like carried out of the room he's
like well maybe if we follow her like
you know through the whole reenactment
we can find out like where she is what
happened to her so they basically do
that so they they follow her ghost
pretty much as she's going through being
murdered again and it turns out that
the strangulation in the cloak room
didn't entirely kill her it just
rendered her unconscious and then the
killer was carrying her she came back to
consciousness and started screaming and
he threw her over a cliff
uh at which point a woman not the same
woman that's the woman in white but this
other woman comes running out of the
cottage uh and this is presumably her
mother and she sees that her daughter is
dead at the bottom of the cliff and she
uh subsequently throws herself off of
the cliff as well
now so all of this stuff is going on
they know where the little girl is like
where she ended up they know what
happened to
her mother
however there's also this whole other
thing where
willie the janitor you know from the
beginning
who has been accused of attacking
frankie in the cloak room because he was
the janitor because he was drunk because
he was on the school grounds and he was
the only one still there but he goes to
trial
and he is actually exonerated because
there is no evidence uh tying him into
the attack
and so his family is obviously very very
happy about it however
uh when he gets off and he goes out to
the car and he's going home and his
family's really happy and everything but
then
like i said this is maybe why you don't
want like little little kids like
watching it because i had totally
forgotten about this real like bummer
kind of development that happened in the
movie so he gets in the car with his
family and he's going home and this
woman comes up to him and previously in
the movie this woman had stood up in
church and basically uh her she was like
the mother of one of the other kids that
was killed uh in the cloakroom or at the
school like over the past decade and um
she was resentful because frankie had
survived and she's like you know why is
your kid better than my kid and she
basically thought that willie the
janitor was the one that had done it and
he was still walking around loose and
she was like resentful about it so there
was like a whole scene in like the
church earlier on where she had kind of
you know let everybody have it
so she comes up to the car um and she
tells him that she wants to apologize
she's like you know obviously you didn't
do it it's like the jury let you off and
everything like that but then uh it will
probably shock no one to hear that
actually she raises a gun and shoots him
right in the [ __ ] head so he gets
he gets off you know because
because he didn't do it and then um
he he didn't even get to leave the
courtroom he was like in a car in front
of the courtroom and this crazy lady
just walked up and shot him in the head
uh so yeah i i had forgotten about that
kind of like really traumatizing
incident so just just know that going in
like i said just it's your mileage may
vary whether you want like a nine or ten
year old kid seeing that i'm sure they
could probably handle it but because you
know
there's a lot worse [ __ ] in movies
nowadays but i'm just saying that's in
there um and like i said there is a big
undercurrent since the movie is set in
1962 uh there is a large undercurrent of
racism you know
kids casually using the n-word and
things like that um because they're
trying to
you know make it kind of seem like it
like it would have been like that small
town life in 1962 so just know that
going in as well
so
after that horrible [ __ ] happens uh they
actually figure out and i don't know if
i want to spoil it or not but who the
actual killer was
by tracing the um
initials on the class ring
and then there's a whole very very good
very tense kind of final act final
battle
against the killer
uh when he discovers that frankie
knows who he is
and uh that's a really really well done
uh well done sequence like i said i
normally would spoil a movie this old
but because i feel like maybe a lot of
people haven't seen it
and because the murder mystery aspect of
this is such a big part of the plot and
about what makes it enjoyable i think
maybe i'll just kind of like leave the
identity but like i said they do kind of
figure out frankie figures out who it is
gino figures out who it is it happens
that frankie is with the person that you
know when he realizes and all this and
there's like a really really tense uh
scene toward the end where he's figures
it out and he you know tries to get away
and it's like really really scary and
then there's kind of like a flashback
too to you know the lady in white who
like i said
there's kind of two ladies in white
because one of them's a ghost but then
one of them is kind of still alive even
though you think she's a ghost like
through the whole kind of thing so
there's that kind of whole thing too and
she ends up coming back into in the
final act and like helping out and all
this other kind of stuff so it's it's
just a really really well constructed
murder mystery ghost story
and i kind of i just kind of feel like
like i said this is a great
halloween
type movie it's just a it's a good
family
movie even though there's like some some
pretty like scary or some pretty like
horrific traumatic [ __ ] in it i mean
like i said there's child murders
there's like like racism and stuff even
though that all's in there just the way
it's portrayed i guess is not
i don't know i don't think i would like
i said i don't have kids i don't think i
would have any hesitation though about
letting like a nine-year-old kid a nine
or ten year old kid watch this um i was
older when this came out
but i still really really liked it and i
was amazed like when i rewatched it how
much of it
i remembered like how many lines from it
i remembered how many scenes from it i
remembered it just really it was one of
those movies that i saw it a bunch of
times you know in 1989 1990 like right
when i was in high school and it just
really kind of like stayed with me uh
just the whole atmosphere of it i don't
know i i just feel like this is the type
of movie that came out in the 80s these
types of family horror movies if that's
not like too weird a thing to say and
it's just it's hard to recreate
the atmosphere that they uh that they
were able to capture you know it just
kind of feels like it's not a
straightforward horror movie it's not a
straightforward family it's not
necessarily a kid's movie but kids can
watch it so it's just it's that kind of
thing and i just i really like movies
like that movies that have that kind of
vibe to them because i feel like they
don't really make a lot of them they
particularly don't make a lot you know
any anymore but they didn't even make a
lot of them back then um and i kind of
feel like this one
maybe
uh has a little has been a little bit
forgotten about you know like i said i
have seen a lot of horror channels
covering it and even you know even on
there like some of the horror reviewers
were younger
and uh seemed like really really into it
and it was interesting too because i was
reading like a lot of the comments and a
lot of younger people that weren't even
alive when this movie was made we're
talking it's like man you know they just
don't make movies like this anymore and
this is so great uh you know it's just
such a great story and just such a great
vibe to it great atmosphere and it's you
know it's genuinely creepy and genuinely
scary like the acting is great like it's
got a great cast it's just i just love
the whole vibe of this and i really feel
like it needs to be kind of
more talked about i suppose you know in
this type of vein now if you want to
watch this
it says it's weird because it says it's
available on hulu and amazon prime
and it is but only if you get i think is
it the cinemax add-on i want to say it's
the cinemax add-on like for hulu at
least you have to have like you have to
get a free trial of one of the other
streaming service add-ons before you can
watch it
however um somebody has some i don't
know who but somebody has uploaded the
whole thing onto youtube for free i will
say though that the picture quality is
pretty shitty
but if you just want to watch the movie
and you don't care about it looking good
um then you can watch it on youtube for
free if not then you're gonna have to go
to hulu or amazon prime and get like one
of their other streaming service add-ons
or at least get a free trial for seven
days or whatever uh to watch it
in in it's beautiful which and i
actually would recommend watching it in
you know high resolution because like i
said there's just this small town
uh autumn
feel to it and it just
you know it loses something when you um
kind of watch it in just shitty you know
420p or whatever the [ __ ] the that one
video is it looks like a vhs rip or
something um you know which which is
kind of a shame but at least it's up
there if people just want to see it to
see what it's like and like i said the
the special effects like the green
screen it hasn't really held up uh it
looks kind of but you know this was a
low budget movie but really that's the
only thing that i can hold against it
that you know the effects look a little
bit dated nowadays
but other than that this is just like a
great and i love
i love ghost stories like this and i
love this whole ghost story murder
mystery uh intertwined type of thing and
especially when you have like a kid at
the center of it um who's trying to like
kind of solve the mystery and it's just
like i feel like that was a very
distinctly 80s type of
uh type of story and i really really
liked it and i'm glad and i'm glad i got
to watch it again like as an adult um to
see if i mean i was almost an adult when
i saw the first time because like i said
it was 1988 1989 when i saw it uh you
know when i was probably 17 i think when
i saw it maybe um but yeah this was
definitely a movie that stuck with me
over the years and i feel like it needs
more attention it needs more
people seeing it um if they're into 80s
horror and haven't seen it then uh
definitely definitely check it out it's
a great one to watch around halloween
time with your family uh as i mentioned
even though there's like some
some [ __ ] in it so it's nice it's a
little bit traumatizing and it is kind
of scary it's pretty scary i mean but
you know
your my mileage may vary on that but a
lot of people uh i have seen a lot of
people talking about it in comments and
stuff saying that they actually did
think it was pretty scary so you know
just know that going in uh if you want
to show it to your kids uh this
halloween or whatever but yeah
definitely check it out it's called the
lady in white came out in 1988 and that
will do it for this flickers of fear and
i will see you guys on the next one
bye